hey there guys
happy friday to you guys so you know a
lot of people obviously looking forward
to this since things were canceled last
year and
this morning we're getting a live look
inside the hyperx esports arena at the
luxor
we're on the second floor on the boss
level
boss level wide because we're about to
walk into a suite
joining us live we have jim he's going
to talk to us about that massive screen
available for families to watch the
games and
so it's a ticketed event but we were
describing it as a family-friendly event
because it's open to all ages
and another thing to note kind of like a
new trend here in town smoke-free good
morning to you good morning
yep all ages so if you want to come in
and watch some basketball
we'll also sit in the lobby and play
some minecraft as absolutely something
you can do with the hyperx esport arena
unique to any other place in las vegas
and uh we were just
talking about this earlier the ticket
basically kind of pays for itself
because it includes a couple of things
yes it includes your seat for all day it
includes five drink tickets and then we
do have an all cart menu that you can
order off of
how excited are you a lot of people
looking forward to it the parking lot
outside looks like it's jam-packed
yeah the ride of passage is here
everybody's looking for the one shiny
moment
i am so glad that march madness has
returned
and i'm glad to be hosting march mayhem
here at the hyperx esport arena
today we were also talking about um what
were we talking about it just escaped to
my mind oh
yeah we were talking about you guys uh
hosting march madness games for the
first time here at this venue yes it we
had planned on doing it last year for
the first time the success that we've
had with the big game over the past
couple years
has moved us into wanting to host the
march mayhem party here at the hyperx
esport arena
and because of the success and and
everybody moving forward with
the the the precautions and safety and
the the ability to be able to bring
people in is something that the
that us and here at the hyperx export
arena can
are more excited than to do and lastly
on that note uh assigned seating
socially distanced temperature checks at
the door
uh talk a little bit about the uh
precautions here yeah so we
everybody that will come in will be temp
checked we do have
sanitation stations all around the arena
everybody is socially distanced apart if
you come together you can stay together
but all of the guests will be socially
distanced apart it's kind of cool though
that bruins and bears and bulldogs
and boilermakers all can come in to
conjugate into one place and have a good
time to watch the basketball a place for
everyone thank you very much so we'll be
going over to the stage next so stay
tuned
we'll be back in half an hour for now
reporting live hector mejia
8 news now back to you guys hector thank
you very much alex looks like a lot of
fun
i know i just want to say it looks a lot
of fun thank you so much hector we'll
see in a few